so Gary we had a question come in via
Twitter from Natalia Gallucci and her
twitter handle is evil artists and hello
Natalia by the way so she writes we have
a consider for our script which tackles
gun violence any tips on how to get it
produced so what are the ways another
the screenwriter can take their scripts
and well I'm not sure where that
coverage comes from that consider is you
know the first page of the coverage the
the the all of the major agencies all of
the major studios as a matter of
practice always always have a script
covered they don't accept a script
unless it goes through the story
Department gets covered first before the
executive or agent reads it those
coverages are protected like better than
the gold in Fort Knox they never get
distributed so number one I'd be curious
where that came from
but regardless I mean by the way
consider it's great because most of them
get passed on in coverage form right so
there's something good about that story
but I wouldn't use that as a tool
I don't think unless you're willing to
unless you can show it and you can
reveal where it came from and who
created it even if you could I'm not
sure it gets you anywhere right because
everyone has to form their own opinion
but what you can say is I've gotten some
very quality feedback from
tried-and-true script analysts in
Hollywood from this company from that
I'm not you know going to bother you to
read that but it gives me confidence to
approach you and say the following
we have spent you know we've done seven
revisions we've gotten a lot of great
feedback the you know it's it's we're
reaching at you because your body of
work your artistic signature is exactly
what we innovate
for this story and we would really love
not you have your development person
rated we are so confident of this we're
not gonna tell you is gonna make a
hundred million dollars we're not
telling us the first epic trilogy we're
not gonna say silly things like that but
you you just really candid with them and
you say you know you evidence the kinds
of positive feedback that you've had and
believe it
you